[Music]  this weekend the thoroughbred racehorse  California chrome failed to win I know  the elusive Triple Crown when he  finished fourth in the Belmont Stakes  now there was a lot of hype about how  California chrome was a lot to win the  Triple Crown and after he lost well it  was quite a tense ride home for the  jockey Victor Espinoza take a look let  me know if I'm going too fast for you no  you're used to a slower pace Belmont  Stakes the amount stakes to Belmont suck  the tomato hopefully Joe  [Applause]  [Music]  surprise there was that rocky cliff in a  suburban area right near that  residential area that doesn't happen  very often yeah just the trees suddenly  the vegetation changed very quickly  you